this is all ours baby I can't believe we
actually get to own it this is crazy
oh yeah we don't have to rent anymore
good morning guys we just got ready
Casey and I just got ready we are gonna
head over to our home
to go see the progress and we're also
gonna go have breakfast also another
thing thank you guys for the suggestion
because I did read in the comments that
someone suggested why don't I just take
extra shoes if I know I'm gonna go visit
the house so I can be wearing proper
shoes because for this outfit I'm doing
D shoes
so those aren't your shoes to wear to go
visit the house so I will be stuffing in
the car
my auberge thank you for that suggestion
suitcases doing oh my god I son Oh how
about you tell me in Chinese use your
culture hello my heart Wow you're not as
stated in Chinese
oh honey I just not gonna say I love you
I don't know how to say terms of
endearment like that like cute
you never hear your parents tell each
other terms of endearment never it's
just hello Paul lope or something yeah
that's kind of cute hey wife alright
after breakfast we decided to come check
up on our home
oops sorry baby I dropped no but look
these are our neighbors houses they're
gotten a lot done
so far okay those my losses totally got
me buzz
so my tongue is really a lazy and loose
okay but anyway oh my goodness look up
but your house has gotten done look at
her fetus home look at the bones and yes
you guys were mentioning how close we
are to our neighbors I mean listen
beggars can't be choosers okay well ease
we have this amount of space between the
homes so oh well this is our
neighborhood this is just the first
floor it looks really small when it's
not built out like just the the framing
on its own I feel like it looks pretty
small it's a small house it is but once
it's fully built out built out though it
does feel bigger in my opinion it's like
when you walk through an empty home like
when you're trying to rent in whatever
or even buying a house you're just
walking through an mplm it feels smaller
and so you put your furniture in there
yeah my sister's space and
psychologically you're like oh yeah
exactly
you know without the walls it does even
smaller yeah yeah weird shall we walk
through our home we did we just found
out that we can we are allowed to walk
through our house because we did sign a
waiver that if we get hurt it's not
their fault so let's walk through it so
this is our garage
this is our garage yep yep and you're
forgetting a third vehicle Oh your
motorcycle yep my motorcycle another my
motorcycle is gonna be part I'm more
scared than excited oh my gosh
relax I'll be okay I'm gonna be very
very safe the more scared I am the more
safe I'll be and I'm pretty scared so
anyway
oh yeah look I'm wearing my all birds
thanks for the suggestion I don't have
to be wearing my sandals while I'm
walking around through all this
construction stuff oh my god I can't
wait oh I forgot to mention last night
we spent about nine or ten hours on
Minecraft building this home so when we
get home we'll show you our home tour a
virtual tour of our home on minecraft
oh yeah look so then we walk in through
the garage and then to my right is our
pantry the first time I ever get to have
a pantry Oh what happened oh because I
brought my hand too so I was like what
and then over here it's gonna be the
stove and then right here is like the
sink and the dishwasher and in the
middle is our kitchen island and then
over here our refrigerator is gonna be
right here or right over there for that
which side this is the view from the
front door you are standing in the
dining room yes and then right here is
our living room yep our living room
right there
and there's like this little Bannister
thing where we can put decorations I
guess this is the front door this is our
coat closet this is our bathroom or
downstairs one toilet bathroom and then
right over here is the stairs to go up
but we can't go up yet because nothing's
there yet
oh yeah and then right over here we're
gonna be putting our piano up against
this window and then right here is the
door to go out to the backyard and then
I think right here is gonna be the AC
unit thingy and then this is all our
backyard this is all for us except that
part over there is a driveway there's a
fence right there it is so small like
this is not even a backyard well I mean
that has a Texan oh yeah it's very small
conduct and in California has big
backyard still like the older homes
backyards can be huge true
so yeah we're low on land real shortage
of land right I know we don't have a lot
of land we're lucky we're even getting
this like this is all ours baby I can't
believe we actually get to own it this
is crazy
oh yeah we don't have to rent anymore so
now this is the front of our home and
then right around here is gonna be our
front yard which is a very baby front
yard but it's okay it's gonna be hours
and then they're telling us that there's
gonna be stairs to go up to our front
door so that's our house you just got
the full path tour a full half door the
full half tourists don't need the whole
upstairs you know what we can give them
the full tour right now with our
neighbors home oh let's go to our
neighbors house mr. Joe is gonna be
walking your house real quick there
Joneses are not
like the safest name you could admit
sniffs all right so our neighbors have
an identical home as ours so let's just
pretend this is our house so this is the
front door this is a coat room this is
the toilet downstairs toilet this is the
living room looks way bigger now yeah
see it's bigger that's the kitchen
you're standing right where the island
would be yeah that's for the
refrigerator the refrigerator is gonna
go on this side and then here's the
pantry the pantry here's the garage see
with walls now you guys get to see it
with walls and then how let's go
upstairs because our neighbors has
stairs let's go up the stairs we go up
the stairs and then when we make a right
this is where we're gonna make our mini
upstairs loft so we're gonna put the TV
there and a couch right there oh dang it
I'm so out of breath I'm so out of shape
we have got another one-story house no I
need this I need the exercises so then
here's the master bedroom
[Music]
master bedroom here's the master
bathroom we go and there's the toilet
room the bathtub shower double sinks I
know me too
showers isn't her sings oh yeah
champagne mm-hmm Isaac oh yeah that'd be
weird if Isaac was involved but yeah and
then look look look this is the closet
okay so we have a pretty huge walk-in
closet I'm so excited for this because
I've never had a walk-in closet this
huge it's always been like the sliding
door kind of closets so I am so hype for
my closet too or for my clothes to have
their own entire room that has a door to
it and everything that's a crazy walk-in
closet anyway let's move on so then you
go over here here is the laundry room
here is the guest bathroom more like the
this would be Isaac's bathroom
technically so he has double sinks as
what as well and then here's a tug
that's full of gross things good thing
this is not our house like critiquing
how we built our house in Minecraft
[Laughter]
walked into the Besser bathroom and I'm
like oh good thing I put the wall there
because that's okay moving on so this is
Isaac's room the bigger one of the two
and in see this is the kind of clog that
I've always had in my life the sliding
door kind of closet and then this would
be the second child whenever they decide
to make their appearance into our lives
room is here and then there's their
closet and then yeah this is our house
well that's technically our neighbor's
house but it's gonna look exactly the
same
all right we are now home with
the boy the boy is home yeah when we
were picking you up Isaac we were
telling you that there was something
that we wanted to share with you but
then we wanted to share with you on
camera so the thing that we wanted to
share with you is we went to visit our
house today mm-hmm right yesterday when
you left you left around like what 12
p.m. or something yeah we were playing
Minecraft until 11:30 last night and the
whole entire time we were creating our
future home in Minecraft Survival
daddy and I like a challenge so right
now we're gonna show you
you got the whole Elgato hooked up into
comfort yeah so now we're gonna give you
a virtual tour of our future home but
it's not exact exact but I think we did
pretty good yeah we did pretty good
given the Minecraft cubes like I know it
kinda make the order like the dimension
a little weird but yeah just building
our future home in a virtual world of
mine and I love what you told me last
night do you remember the comment that
you said about the future oh yeah one
day will be like 80 years old sitting on
our porch and be like honey we're not
one time in our in our younger days I'm
gonna be built their home and then the
Minecraft our starter home you know what
else is funny is like last night we were
trying to do what we're trying to do I
forgot what we did but I think we're
trying to save it or you're trying to
sign out or something
we ended up signing out we couldn't sign
back in like let me back into the game
world I think in a second there we got a
building a finish for the house I know
so can you help us how do we get back
and can't wait you guys
see what you guys did no I can't wait to
show you this is like 10 hours of work
it is just an hours of dedication right
here less sweat and tears oh here we go
oh okay all right on the front give me a
tour
let me look down all right Ellie's doh
all right so we're gonna give you guys a
virtual tour of our house features so
you guys walk through like the bones
over-analysis yeah today I showed you
right exactly like the whole framing and
then our neighbor's house which looks
like tentacle to our house with like the
walls all up and now this is a Minecraft
version yeah we won't have an actual pig
in our in our yard but the house itself
we won't have this much you already
there now our yard is way smaller you
have a beaver right next door
how did you get those materials
terracotta terracotta baby this world
has Harry Potter like lots of it look at
the front whistle we walk in remember
that little Bannister thing on the side
of the house hmm and then this is the
living room we haven't fixed it yet my
bed still there this is the coat closet
[Music]
move fast here this is the downstairs
bathroom the toilets gonna be right
there hmm I wish we had like home items
really creative and good now I know we
still need to put our dining table here
in like our living room stuff here but
yeah this is a kitchen and then we've
got its die right for the countertops Oh
oh yeah like granite so this is like
that counter space and then this is
where the fridge is gonna go but we have
a crafting table instead hmm
and then right here is where the stoves
gonna be so we put the furnace and then
right here is the dishwasher so we've
put a chest and I here's the sink to
wash dishes and then here's our island
thank you over here is the pantry so we
have another box and then we see like
the stairs
ooh but we have another and then let's
look upstairs in a pretty big house yeah
it's a little bit bigger than real life
for sure yeah and then we have our lost
and it's a dent identical yeah the
windows exactly we're in this thing
really again we were wearing it today
you're staring at me real actually like
that's exactly where I put it up and
then through here is the master bedroom
hmm and then through here is the
bathroom the master bathroom and then
here the double sinks we got a bit more
thigh right there we have standing
standing dirt piles over the bathtub
and this is the bathtub and then right
here is the toilet it's super tiny
immigrant like in real life
yeah and then I realized today oh I took
down the wall okay so there needs to be
a wall right here with the door do you
put the closet because a little bit of
it won't come close it's a major walk-in
closet that I was raving about today in
the block and then what is this okay we
gotta fix this
yeah a little bit of remodeling yeah we
had to remodel this so I staring at this
end of the hallway that is not how our
house is enough the door supposed to go
over here right yeah I forgot already
good mmm go ahead no began so continuing
this is the laundry room
oh yeah right mm-hmm yeah laundry room
that's right but this is the bathroom
wait the other way around
oh this is the laundry room yeah I don't
remember you know what and that means
the bathroom is kind of wrong because
the bathrooms supposed to be more narrow
longer it would no gate has to shut out
yes we need to extend that wall outwards
it's a lot of work okay and then this
one is your room I think oh wait can you
see something yeah you found a mess of
biome what messed up yeah that's a mess
of I oh yeah it's right across from
rileys good because there if you if you
mind you can easily find gold right
there we are so rich in this yeah
in that in a burner - got hard of it
daddy had two sheep down there - yeah
Nessa biomes are like popular because
it's filled legal like it's basically
right like cooler that's a cold lots of
gold
lots of terracotta - yeah Jericho it's
hard to find sometimes you just dig deep
yeah here's the other room
I forget which was your room never like
it's gonna be that one the one that's
the next one the one is on the side of
the laundry room yeah yeah this is on
the garage yeah so our garage is this
we're gonna have a later river for
garage yeah that's this that's the back
road my car which oh it's a Tesla yeah
they're both the same
oh it was like pretty like
I'm glad you like it this look back at
it it took us an eternity to do the like
staring at Rome look at that it's just
no garage I forgot to show you yeah let
me show you one last thing and then and
then I'm done I forgot to show you how
accurate our house is what on the close
the door
this takes forever I don't know how you
close the door oh I'm running through it
and I think is really fascinating
you're getting like annoying remember
this door to me and outside and then we
made it indent to just like big mouth
like the real life oh yeah I was gonna
say like oh did you guys do that yeah
that's this time we need to build up
fences thank you
good I hear you I got you yes tree oh
and it's been so frustrating Isaac
because this world has so many freaking
creepers they keep exploding our house
they blew up that corner right there
that's why all of this right here -
there's been so many moles we wouldn't
have you feel like patch it up get out
of here you saw be good yeah the next
steps is purpo fence and keep shooters
so these stupid creepers stop exploding
our skin and move our beds move our beds
into the master bedroom in your and
build the best for use if you have a bed
but that's the tour that's the tour love
it yes I love it I know and then I was
we were talking about it - were like we
need to make Isaac a bed and put it in
his bedroom true is there an Arab girl
yeah oh my gosh there's so many aro guys
in this world - welcome to our house and
I can't wait to actually walk through
our real house and give you guys the
real-life tour rather than a virtual
tour today
they were sick well we didn't really
like to help our neighbors out but they
did say that our home will be finished
maybe like mid-january so by your
birthday and it's a lot of fingers
crossing and then you need to do this
your toes your toes your eyes your
tongue thanks for watching guys see you
in the next video bye
[Music]
[Music]